RIP.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Tachchen.
So, und jetzt machen wir Internet.
Da ist man dann endlich wieder zu Hause.
Genau, jetzt ist es ja so, dass das Internet, so wie wir es heute kennen, ist ja nicht immer so dick und schnell gewesen. Das war ja am Anfang ein bisschen langsamer. Jetzt ist so, meine Erinnerung ist es so, der erste große Filesharing-Dienst, der, ich sag jetzt mal, IP-basiert im Netz, also die sagen, über diese Netzwerk- irgendwie Sachen funktioniert, waren LAN-Partys. Also das heißt, noch mal irgendwo hingehen und dann Dateien tauschen, weil das Internet selber noch zu langsam war.
Da hatte man dann irgendwann nicht mehr seine Disketten mitgenommen auf die Partys, um sie dort zu tauschen, sondern da nahm man gleich den gesamten Computer mit, stellte ihn dann dahin und hatte in der Zwischenzeit, wie man sich da über das LAN die Daten seiner Freunde kopiert hat, dann auch gleich noch Spiele gespielt. Und daher kommt auch die öffentliche Wahrnehmung, dass man diesen LAN-Partys größtens jetzt geballert würde. Ich glaube, so einer der Hauptgründe war, einfach einen LAN aufzumachen und dort zu gucken, was an spannenden Programmen spielen, Musik bei den Freunden rum. Obwohl, Musik war so früh doch gar nicht dabei, weil da gab es die Mods, diese kleinen Musikstücke, die da liebevoll von Programmierern noch zusammengestückelt wurden, die dann auch eine handliche Größe hatten, dass sie noch mit Disketten draufpassten. So wie heute so MP3s, die Qualität war das noch nicht. Oder so Chiptunes, die wir gerade gehört haben, war bei den C64 Hackern immer ganz beliebt und die wurden dann natürlich auch getauscht. Also Musik tauschen damals auch, vor MP3 war es einfach unrealistisch, so viel Daten mitzunehmen.
Wobei das damals natürlich zum größten Teil selbstgemachte Musik war. Das ist dann die ganze Ecke, Demo-Szene und so weiter und so fort. Also viel von dem, was damals getauscht wurde, war dann auch selbstgemachte und handgestrickte Musik. Also die normale Musik aus dem Radio, die konnte man nicht nehmen und auf eine Diskette tun, sondern das war spezielle für den Computer programmierte Musik.
Okay, aber ansonsten diese LAN-Partys war jetzt auch irgendwie so keine technische Herausforderung, oder? Also die spannende Frage war da, wie du sagen willst, da ging es ja nochmal um den Kopierschutz, dass der irgendwie weggekriegt werden musste?
Na, das war meistens schon fertig, das brachte man auf seiner Festplatte mit und dass auf den LAN-Partys da selber noch irgendwas Proaktives passiert, das kam auf die Szene an. Es gab natürlich in der Demoprogrammiererszene und in der Cracker-Szene gab es natürlich dann auch, dass man noch schnell auf Partys, wo man dann am Ende eine Demo vorgeführt hat, den Code fertig gemacht hat oder noch schnell den Trainer für den Crack, den man gemacht hat, noch schnell fertig programmiert und dann dazu zeigen, aber ansonsten auf den LAN-Partys selber eher so Konsum.
Das erste Mal, wo man sich über Technik nicht mehr so richtig viel Gedanken machen musste und dann hat damals auch schon eine Rolle gespielt, also als es das langsame Internet gab, noch über Modems, eine Sache, die heute immer als Werbung manchmal auftaucht im Netz, ist Usenet. Das ist ja, muss ich ehrlich gestehen, ein Teil dieser ganzen Netzgeschichte, die sowohl damals als auch heute komplett ausgelassen habe. Was ist das Usenet eigentlich und wie tauscht man dort Dateien?
Das Usenet ist also aus den Zeiten, wo es noch kein WWW gab im Internet, für viele Leute ist es ja dasselbe, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass dieses Webklicken im Protokoll irgendwann dazugekommen ist. Das Usenet ist älter. Das kann man sich vorstellen als eine Art verteiltes Forum. Das heißt, es gibt nicht irgendwie einen Rechner, auf dem ein Forum zu einem Thema ist, sondern es gibt viele Rechner, die viele Foren zu allen Themen haben und untereinander austauschen. Technisch funktioniert das als so ein nettes Flatfill-Verfahren. Das heißt, man hat Server, die reden miteinander. Dann schreibt man seine Textnachricht, so was wie, hallo, ich bin heute Morgen aufgestanden, das Wetter war schön, wie geht es euch so? Ja, ein bisschen ausführlicher. Man hat schon mehr als 140 Zeichen gehabt, also es war ein bisschen moderner, dieses Protokoll, als Twitter. Und dann hat man das an seinen News Server geschickt, eine sogenannte News Group. News Groups gab es die großen sieben Hierarchien, also die waren geordnet nach zum Beispiel SCI für Science, für wissenschaftliche, Recreational, was gab es noch, COM für Computer und SOC für Society. Und da gab es ALT, Altstand für Alternative und für alles andere. Und so die ersten Pornos, die ich runtergeladen habe, waren also in Textformen und kamen aus ALT.erotica hieß es glaube ich, genau, ALT.erotica, News Groups, erotische Texte. Und irgendwann haben sie auch angefangen, darüber Dateien auszutauschen. Aber Flatfill, genau. So ich schreibe meine Nachricht, ich schicke das an meinen lokalen Server in eine bestimmte News Group. Und mein News Server, mein Usernet News Server ist verbunden mit anderen Servern. Und redet mit denen, sagt denen, pass mal auf, ich habe eine neue Nachricht mit folgender Nachrichten ID. Dann sagen die auf der anderen Seite, ne, habe ich noch nicht. Und dann schickt er dem das rüber. Das schicke ich also, schickt den News Server in alle Richtungen an alle angeschlossenen Server. Irgendwann passiert das natürlich, dass die Nachricht überall ist. Das heißt, der nächste News Server sagt seinem Nachbarn, du, ich habe hier eine Nachricht, eine andere sagt, kenne ich schon. Und dann ist die überall, so nennt es Flat Filling. Funktioniert wunderbar, funktioniert auch, wenn man News Server wegfällt, weil dann läuft es einen anderen Weg, ist also sehr, sehr resistent. Kommt auch aus Zeiten von Vor-IP, also das funktioniert auch schon über Modems mit USCP, aber dann über IP so richtig. Und da sind Leute darauf gekommen, dass man damit ja auch Dateien austauschen kann, und zwar indem man die Dateien als Textnachrichten codiert. Man nimmt also sein Binary, zerlegt das in ganz viele Stücke und dann heutzutage würde man Base64 nehmen, gab es damals noch nicht, wurde UU-Encoded und dann hat man also sein Spiel genommen, da 100 Textnachrichten draus gemacht, dann gab es Alt-Binaries-Vers-PC-Games und dann hat man da sein Spiel hochgeladen.
Aber ich kann mir jetzt wirklich vorstellen, also man kann das ja heute spaßeshalber machen, man nimmt einen Rechner eine ausführbare Datei, öffnet die mit einem Textelitor, dann stehen da verschwurbelte Zeichen.
Genau.
Und das hat man dann quasi so was, im Prinzip hat man dann in dieses Usenet reingepostet als Textnachricht, 100-fach, 100 kleine Stücken.
Man kann sich vorstellen, dass diese Textnachrichten dann einfach die binäre Repräsentation sind. Also so ein Byte ist ja eine Zahl von 0 bis 255, bestehend aus zwei hexadezimalen Zahlen. Und die einfachste Möglichkeit, das zu entkoden, wäre einfach da 0 bis 9 und A bis F rauszumachen und dann aus einem Byte mal 2 zu machen. So kann man sich das vorstellen, dass da dann was, naja, ist nicht menschenlesbar, aber es geht zumindest dann, weil es nicht mehr binär ist, geht es als Textnachricht durch.
Und musste man das von Hand machen, oder gab es dann dafür auch?
Ja, da gibt es natürlich Software. EMAX konnte das. EMAX war aber nicht die einzige Software. Ich kenne tatsächlich Leute, die haben das von Hand gemacht. Die haben dann alle 100 Nachrichten von Hand runtergeladen, von Hand zusammengesetzt und weggeschrieben. Und ich war total liet, weil ich konnte in EMAX mit Regular Expressions sagen, setze mir das zusammen und pack es mir am Stück aus.
Aber das ist gar nicht so antiquiert. Ich meine, wenn du mal in eine Mail rein guckst, was meinst denn du, was da in deiner Mail reinkommt? Sind das Binär-Daten?
Der Mail ist antiquiert.
Nee, in der Mail hängen hinten auch noch UDABase64 encoded.
Wir verlassen dem Pfad des allgemeinen verständlichen Radioprogramms.
Ich wollte nur sagen, die Art und Weise, wie da Text draus gemacht wurde aus binären Programmen, ist heute immer noch dieselbe, wenn du eine E-Mail empfängst. Deswegen ist die immer noch ein bisschen größer als die eigentlich zu verschickende Datei.
Also, Usenet war lange sehr, sehr wichtig. Wie gesagt, vor Erfindung des Webs war es eigentlich einer von drei oder vier Services, die man so hat im Internet. Das erste Protokoll, das erfunden wurde, war Dateitransfer natürlich. FDP stammt aus den frühen 70ern. Hat tatsächlich auch als Verbreitungsmedium für Wärs lange Zeit eine Rolle gespielt. Also Leute haben sich FDP-Server gesucht. Möglichst welche, wo man was hochladen konnte und dann haben die einfach hochgeladen, dann ist die URL rumgegangen und gut war. Nee, der Pfadname URLs gab es ja auch nicht. Dann gab es Chat. Also, IRC ist auch ein relativ altes Protokoll, ist Ende der 80er entstanden. Mails, SMTP und Usenet. Das waren so die vier wichtigen Kommunikationsmedien, die man im Internet hatte, bevor das Web angefangen hat. Und also alles, was heutzutage in Foren abgehandelt wird, ist darüber passiert und deswegen hatte das auch jeder. Also jede Universität hatte ihren News Server. Und CompuServe war ja damals irgendwie, also bevor das Internet populär wurde, gab es ja verschiedene Versuche, proprietäre gegen Internetse aufzubauen. AOL erinnert sich vielleicht der eine oder andere, CompuServe war so eins. Und die haben sich irgendwann ergeben und haben gesagt, okay, ja gut, wir machen auch Internet. Man hatte bei seinem Provider halt immer seinen News Server zu stehen, zu dem man sich verbunden hat. Und da kamen natürlich auch immer alle Bineries drüber. Und da gab es damals einen relativ wichtigen rechtlichen Streit drüber, CompuServe. Da gab es also eine Klage gegen den Geschäftsführer von CompuServe Deutschland wegen illegalen Raubmordkopien auf News Servern. CompuServe hat damals gewonnen, übrigens. Was der Grund ist, dass es das Usenet tatsächlich immer noch gibt.
Also das war zum ersten Mal die Frage, ob der Übermittler der Nachrichten auch dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden kann, dass da Raubkopien durchgehen.
Genau, genau. Das, was man heutzutage als Providerprivileg kennt, wurde damals also ausgestritten. Ob derjenige, der diesen News Server betreibt, dafür verantwortlich ist, was seine Nutzer da hochladen und darüber kommt.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass Usenet, wie ihr es gerade beschrieben habt, sozusagen eine Ansammlung von Text, den man auch irgendwie missbrauchen kann, um Dateien auszutauchen.
Das ist ja nicht Missbrauch, das ist ja der Gebrauch.
Ja, und jetzt gibt es aber dieses letzte Mal Usenet heute noch. Also es blinkt in Bananen auf irgendwie. Wenn Freunde im Internet danach was suchen, dann tauchen sie auch hier, laden sie das Usenet runter, bezahlen aber Geld. Ist das noch dasselbe Usenet oder ist das nur der Name?
Das ist noch dasselbe Usenet, aber im Laufe der Zeit war einfach dieses Flat Fill, was Andreas beschrieben hat. Ist natürlich, wenn du anfängst, riesige Datenmengen, ganze DVDs da hochzuladen, da wird das echt viel Traffic. Und da hatten viele Leute keinen Bock mehr drauf. Und dann haben sie gesagt, naja, für diese ganzen Diskussionen, Sports, machen wir es einfach weiter. Die kann man weiter einfach so kostenlos abonnieren. Aber die ganzen Binärkanäle da, so Alt-Binary, die synchronisieren wir einfach nicht. Wenn da jemand etwas bei uns absetzen möchte, dann fragen wir gar nicht nach dieser Nachricht. Haben wir aber diesen einen schönen, kostenpflichtigen Dienst, bei dem geht das. Da kannst du dann, damit wir diese Informationen von den Gegenstellen reinbekommen, müssen wir den Traffic bezahlen, kostet uns Geld, und deswegen verkaufen wir es dann weiter als kostenpflichtigen Service. Und so wurde es dann zum Zweiklassen-Usenet, wo man dann den schmalen Textversionskram natürlich immer noch bekommen hat. Einfach so, aber wenn man Binärdaten runterladen wollte, hat man dann dafür bezahlt. Und dieses Modell hat sich dann im Laufe der Zeit weiterentwickelt, sodass es heute Leute gibt, die einfach auf demselben Protokoll, aber auf richtig großen, dicken, angebundenen Servern, die die Möglichkeit per UUCP, also diesem Protokoll, was im Usenet gesprochen wird, auch Binärdaten runterzuladen. Und du bezahlst da eigentlich dafür, dass sie dir so bulletproof das anbieten. Na, du kannst eigentlich nicht belangt werden. Du machst eine sichere Verbindung zu diesem Verserver auf, zu diesem UU-Netserver auf. Und wo der die Daten herbekommt, ist dir egal. Und du hoffst einfach darauf, dass er schon nicht die Downloads mit dir assoziiert. Und dann am Ende dem Strafverfolger.
Du hoffst darauf, dass er nicht die Kim Schmitz macht? Okay, das also zum Usenet. Und dann ging es ja richtig los mit dem, ich nenne es jetzt im Mangel eines anderen Begriffs, mit dem richtigen Internet. Napster, anyone? Also war Napster nicht sozusagen... 4 zu 4 sagste, ja. Also war das nicht der Beginn des großen übers Netz Filesharing auch für den Normalverbrauch? Also nicht Leute, die sich irgendwie auskannten, sondern mehr oder weniger für jedermann.
Ja, also in den Anfangszeiten, da war auch Napster und Nutella waren noch Programme für die Nerds, bevor sie dann ein schönes Use-Enterface bekommen haben. Aber die Nerds haben dann schon... Da war dann auch die Zeit, wo dann MP3s das erste Mal aufkamen, wo dann auch wirklich... Dann was auch Leute da draußen interessierte. Also so mit Software, auch noch gekrackte Software, wo man sich nicht sicher war, war dann halt nicht für jeden. Aber als es dann plötzlich auch Musikdateien gab, da waren dann plötzlich diese Dienste, die einem per Peer-to-Peer, also was heißt, von einem sehr entschärmten Bekannten, sich Musik herunterzuladen, war dann plötzlich voll am Wog. Man konnte dann die CD, die man sich eigentlich hätte kaufen müssen, für umme... Na ja, herunterladen. Sie materialisierte sich, wenn man sie irgendwo gefunden hatte, in diesem Netz, plötzlich auf der eigenen Festplatte. Und man konnte sie dann mit so Vim-Emp oder was man auf seiner Plattform hatte, dann auch anhören und musste die CD nicht mehr kaufen. Da hatte man auch einen handfesten Geldwerten Vorteil. Und dasselbe gilt natürlich auch für Spiele. Sodass es dann das erste Mal im Mainstream angekommen ist damit und nicht nur die Nerds interessiert hat. Aber das waren damals echt noch hakelig Protokolle, wo man einen Ordner hinlegen musste. Und dann hat dieses Programm da durchgescannt. Und dann musstest du nach Dateinamen suchen. Und dann hat er dann mit allen anderen, mit denen du da verbunden warst, mal gefragt, sag mal, habt ihr die Datei? Und die haben dann weiter gefragt. Und dann ging das so explosionsartig, zehn Schritte weiter. Und wenn irgendjemand durch Zufall bei einem seiner verbundenen anderen Notes diese Datei gefunden hat, dann hat er gesagt, ja, gibts da. Und dann konnte man sich dahin verbinden und den Dateitransfer starten. Hört sich, naja, ziemlich ineffizient an. Und war es auch. Und deswegen hat es niemals etwas kaputtgehoben.
Aber kurz so, dass alle Rechner im Prinzip mehr oder weniger miteinander geredet haben und direkt ohne eine zentrale Instanz, oder?
Ja, also es gab natürlich immer zentrale Instanzen, um erstmal noch eine Liste der gerade aktiven IP-Adressen. Also man muss es ja irgendwie seeden. Also man muss dafür sorgen, dass man wenigstens mal ein paar hat, die schon in diesem Verbundnetz dabei sind. Und die wurden immer noch von einer zentralen Stelle ausgeliefert. Aber ansonsten war danach die Information, wer sonst noch in diesem Netzwerk beteiligt ist, wurde dann schon peer-to-peer auch mit ausgetauscht.
Also zwischen allen Nutzern quasi. Ist das dann rechtlich eine andere Sache gewesen? Oder ist das dann immer noch, sprechen wir immer noch hier vom ja, Privatkopien, oder ging es dann los, ist das eigentlich jeder Teilnehmer auch, dass dann diese Uploader, Downloader Unterteilung?
Das ist ja schon keine geschlossene Benutzergruppe mehr. Also damit kannst du schwerlich noch irgendwie argumentieren. Also bei so einer Mailbox, wo alle theoretischen Zugangsschlüssel haben müssen, um daran teilzuhaben, kann man ja argumentieren, das sind das meine Freunde, aber spätestens dann, wenn automatisch neue Peers hinzugefügt werden, die irgendwo im Netz gefunden werden, ist es einfach keine geschlossene Benutzergruppe. Du wirst echt eine harte Zeit haben, den Richt dazu erklären, dass das noch eine Privatkopie, die du nur Freunden zur Verfügung stellst, ist.
Jetzt habe ich irgendwie im Ohr, dass es sowas gibt, wie Download aus offensichtlich rechtswidriger Quelle ist illegal, aber wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann nicht. Stimmt das oder ist das was Gutes da?
Ja, also wir kennen diese Formulierung ziemlich gut, also die offen kundige rechtswidrige Quelle. Gute Frage, was ist es? Das hat sich leider in den letzten Jahren so verschärft, dass es sämtliche Filesharings sind. Also wenn nicht der Rechteinhaber dieses Produkt zur Verfügung stellt, dann muss man davon ausgehen, dass es eben eine Zwischenquelle ist. Also jemand, der zwischengeschaltet ist. Und dann soll es schon offen kundig sein. Also ganz klar hier wird argumentiert, um ein bestimmtes Ergebnis zu erreichen, dass man sich mit diesen einzelnen Portalen da nicht auseinandersetzen muss, was ist jetzt noch glaubwürdig oder was nicht etc. Sondern entweder wir haben eben anerkannte Verwerter. Das ist dann offen kundig rechtmäßig. Und die anderen Bereiche, die fallen dann unter unsicher. So und da wird aber kaum zugestanden, dass man das nicht erkennen konnte, dass hier auch Daten zum Kopieren bereitgehalten werden, wo halt Lizenzrechte verletzt werden.
Es gibt zum Beispiel, was ich dann immer gerne ranziehe, es gibt eine Plattform, die heißt recordlabel.com, also ohne die Vokale. Und da werden Remixe von bekannten Songs, also von auch bekannten Künstlern zur Verfügung gestellt und auch manchmal von neuen Stars quasi. Und das gibt es schon sehr lange und das ist auch legal, weil die Künstler da mitmachen. Aber wenn jetzt so ein unbedarfter User dahin kommt, kann er das quasi eigentlich nicht unterscheiden. Weil das sind nicht die Künstler selber, die das halt anbieten, sondern das ist halt auf jeden Fall so eine Art Magazin, Musikmagazin, die da Downloads anbieten. Das heißt, er müsste nach der aktuellen Rechtsprecher eigentlich sagen, ok, ich lade da nichts runter, weil das ist für mich schon offensichtlich rechtswidrig.
Ja, das ist schwer, das abzugrenzen. Das ist eine Ausdehnung, die man natürlich bezweckt, um sämtliche Möglichkeiten zu minimieren, dass hier Kopien hergestellt und ausgetauscht werden, die halt vom Lizenzrecht nicht gedeckt sind. Also das ist schwierig in dem Bereich, wirklich noch zu sagen, das ist hier überhaupt nicht offenkundig. Ich hätte damit überhaupt nicht rechnen müssen, dass ich hier irgendwelche Rechte verletze. Aber man muss eben sich angucken, wer dahinter steckt. Also da ist eine harte Lobby dahinter. Die ist deshalb so hart, weil es um so sehr viel Geld geht. Und man versucht auf sehr vielen Ebenen eben zu unterbinden, diese ganze Tauscherei und Kopieren. Und das ist eine Art natürlich.
Also einfach so sagen, so viel Unsicherheit streuen, dass die Leute sich nicht mehr trauen. Ist die Unterscheidung zwischen Uploadern und Downloadern, wenn so Dinge verfolgt werden? Was genau ist da der Unterschied, der wichtige Juristische?
Ja, juristisch, das hat ja angefangen natürlich mit den Uploadern, also diejenigen, die das zur Verfügung stellen, aber auch die werden verfolgt zivilrechtlich, die sich die Sachen auch runterladen auf dem PC. Also juristisch ist da jetzt kein Unterschied mehr. Das einzige, wo jetzt juristischen Unterschied wäre, wenn ich ohne Lizenz Daten zur Verfügung stelle als Uploader und dafür Geld bekomme.
Aber ich habe das irgendwie so im Ohr, dass gerade irgendwie, wenn es um BitTorrent dann später geht, dass die Leute immer deswegen belangt werden, weil sie etwas hochladen und seltener, weil sie etwas runtergeladen haben.
Ja, der Eingriff, der ist intensiver. Natürlich geht man mehr oder möchte mehr die Leute vom Markt holen, die Uploaden, aber auch diejenigen sind betroffen, die downloaden. Also wenn ich mir das Album von Casper runterlade, dann besteht tatsächlich die Gefahr, dass ich hier auch abgemahnt werde.
Die Unterteilung der Verfolger sagen, wir malen jetzt erstmal nur alle Uploader ab, ist tatsächlich eher willkürlich von den Rechteinhabern, weil es einfacher ist.
Also sie nehmen, was ist einfacher, die Uploader oder die Downloader?
Die Uploader zu verfolgen.
Das weiß ich nicht, was jetzt technisch da einfacher ist, die zu verfolgen. Aber es wurde ja auch rumgebrüllt, dass man die Streamer abmahnen möchte. Also man möchte an alle ran, die mit Daten ihre Freizeit verbringen, etc. ohne Lizenz.
Eigentlich sollen die alle wechseln, sondern nach dem passenden Gesetz gesucht.
Aber es reicht da glaube ich erstmal ein paar Exempel zu statuieren. Muss man aufpassen, dass man da nicht gerade eine arme, alleinerziehende Mutter und irgendwie zwölfjähriges Kind erwischt. Aber ansonsten ist von der GVU die Strategie auch ganz knallhart, diese Fälle dann ganz groß in die Presse zu schleifen, wo irgendjemand dann auch als Konsument einfach große Summen bezahlt hat, um da den abschreckenden Effekt zu erzeugen.
Aber sind wir denn noch bei Exempel statuieren? Also die Zahl, die ich kenne, sind, dass die Verwaltungsgesellschaften pro Monat in Deutschland 300.000 User-IPs sich holen.
Das sind ja die Abmahnanwälte selber, die da hergehen. Das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Instanzen. Also die GVU ist ja die Front dafür, der Strommann dafür, dass die Leute nicht auf den Musiklabels rumkloppen und die einen schlechten Namen bekommen. Die haben sich zusammengeschlossen. Und die GVU ist jetzt eine Gesellschaft, die das lobbied, die Werbung dafür macht, dass man nicht raubgruppiert und dass man im Knast landet und dass man dort im Knast vergewaltigt wird. Und dass man wieder nach dem Fall... Das waren den Werbespots drin. Also das ist irgendwie von...
Tatsächlich?
Ja, das sind Original-GVU-Werbespots. Da ging so ein kleiner, bleicher Nerd, der dann wieder reingepackt worden ist. Und dann haben sie dann die ganzen anderen Insassen in dem Gefängnis gezeigt, so große, brutale Männer.
Also das ist unfassbar. Man muss richtig, richtig viele Urheberrechtsverletzungen begehen, um dann erst in den Knast zu kommen. Also das dauert eine Weile. Also nicht beim ersten, nicht beim zweiten, nicht beim dritten Vergehen kommt man in den Knast. Das geht nicht so schnell. Das ist harte Werbung.
Die Art und Weise, wie sie dich versuchen, ranzubekommen, ist gerade einfach generell gewerbsmäßiges Hoch- und Runterladen von Dateien, die es unterstellen. Also wenn du an Tauschbörsen teilnimmst von irgendwas, was gerade noch draußen verkauft wird, dann ist es eigentlich erstmal gewerbsmäßig. Und du hast ziemlich einen Ärger, das dann auch vor Gerichte zu schleifen. Das ist so gerade ihre Strategie, mit der sie auch meistens durch die unteren Instanzen in den Gerichten durchkommen.
Ja, da muss ich mich verbessern. Also wenn es um Gewerbsmäßigkeit geht, dann ist das immer eine Qualifizierung. Und da kommt man schnell.
Und die Gewerbsmäßigkeit ist dann wieder Verhandlungssache ab, wann was gewerbsmäßig ist. Da geht es dann anscheinend nicht immer nur darum, ob man Geld dafür nimmt, sondern da geht es manchmal auch darum, ob es jetzt der aktuelle Film ist, der gerade im Kino ist.
Naja, also, dass ich das gewerblich betreibe, also, dass ich das regelmäßig mache, um damit Geld zu verdienen.
Also, das Geld spielt eine Rolle. Solange ich kein Geld dafür nehme, ist es nicht gewerbsmäßig.
Also, sie versuchen es dir erstmal zu unterstellen. Also, das ist auch das, womit sie... Es gibt ja... es gab ja jetzt diese Regelung, dass, wenn du nur Dateien heruntergeladen hast und das nur im kleinen Stil betreibst, dass es dann eine Deckelung der Anwaltskosten gibt. Weil diese ganzen Massenabmahnungen natürlich keine anwaltlichen... kein anwältlicher Aufwand mehr ist. Und das unterlaufen sie eigentlich regelmäßig. Sie setzen doch ihre hohen Anwaltsgebühren an und sagen dann, das ist aber nicht einfach nur privates Kopieren auf den Rechner, sondern das ist schon gewerbsmäßig. Und damit rechtfertigen sie dann gerade noch die hohen Rechtsanwaltsgebühren. Und da muss man dann erst gegenwider vorgehen. Und das ist wahrscheinlich billiger, wenn man keinen eigenen Anwalt bemüht, sondern einfach da Zähneknurschen bezahlt. Und das ist da, wo sie darauf auch spekulieren.
Jetzt ist es auch so, wir waren gerade bei Napster stehen geblieben. Und wenn ich das jetzt so grobe blicke, alles, was danach kam, ist mehr oder weniger, also bis auf die Sharehouse, die wir nochmal extra besprechen müssen, ist das mehr oder weniger peer to peer. Also es gab dann verschiedene Protokolle und Clients, also LimeWire und Knutella und weiß der Geier, Donkey, Soulseeker. Und das endete irgendwann sozusagen in BitTorrent.
Na es gibt da noch eine wichtige Unterscheidung, ob du den Index auch innerhalb deines peer to peer Netzes betreibst, oder ob du nochmal eine zentrale oder dezentrale Instanz hast, um andere Leute zu finden, die auch die Datei, nach der du gerade suchst, zu...
Also der Unterschied zwischen BitTorrent und allen anderen Diensten ist, dass es bei BitTorrent so ist, dass es sozusagen erstmal wissen musst, was du runterlädst und dann ist nur der Download selber sozusagen peer to peer?
Ja, aber es gab auch in anderen Diensten gab es dann einen fertigen Index, wo du dann den E-Donkey Link zum Beispiel bekommen hast, wo du die runterladen möchtest.
Ich würde gerne noch sagen, bevor wir dazu kommen, noch gerne wissen, wann ist denn Napster eigentlich zugemacht worden? Die sind ja sozusagen juristisch aus der Welt geschafft worden, mehr oder weniger, diese ganzen Firmen.
Ich glaube, die wurden gekauft. Napster wurde tatsächlich, die haben einen großen Batzen Geld bekommen und dann gab es irgendjemanden, der sich in den Kopf gesetzt hat, da könnte man doch irgendein Geschäftsmodell daraus machen, aber ich glaube, das Geschäftsmodell war tatsächlich irgendwie, die einfach von der Szene zu kriegen, aufzukaufen und das zu sagen, dass es nicht mehr gibt.
Aber haben die das wirklich mit allen gemacht? Es gab ja verschiedene Anbieter nach demselben Prinzip.
Nein, natürlich ist, da ist halt Geld und einige in der Verwertungsindustrie sind halt auch nicht total bekloppt und haben gesehen, dass wenn man das in großem Stile aufzieht und bequem seinen Usern anbietet, dann haben die da wahrscheinlich auch Lust darauf, Geld auszugeben. Also natürlich kann man offiziell behaupten, die Kids würden eh alle nichts bezahlen wollen, aber just kam ein größerer Forschungsbatzen raus, wo festgestellt wurde, dass Leute einen festen Betrag haben, den sie pro Monat für Musik und Recreational Content ausgeben und der flukruiert nicht groß. Und die meisten wollen auch einfach ihre Musik besitzen und irgendwo Geld dafür hinlegen, soll halt sie nur nicht unnötig beanspruchen und das soll auch nicht in schlechterer Qualität und mit mehr Hesselverboten verbunden sein.
Ja, aber das hört sich jetzt an, als ob wirklich die, das hört sich wirklich an, als ob diese Art von Dateiaustausch sozusagen weggekauft wurde. Da gab es doch aber wahrscheinlich auch Rechtssachen.
Also wenn sozusagen der Kern deine Frage ist, warum gibt's Napster und Nutella und LimeWire und E-Donkey nicht mehr, dann ist der Grund, weil BitTorrent technisch viel besser funktioniert.
Ah, technisch abgelöst, nicht juristisch.
Ja, also die Verwertungsindustrie hat sich eingebildet, man könnte das Problem aus der Welt schaffen, indem man einen Teil davon aufkauft. Das ist natürlich kompletter Unsinn, aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass BitTorrent einfach technisch enorme Vorteile hat und deswegen die anderen Peer-to-Peer-Protokolle abgelöst hat.
Alles klar, dann kommen wir dazu gleich. Wir erklären das ein bisschen genauer, wie es funktioniert und ob das möglicherweise in Zukunft sein konnte. Vorher machen wir aber noch einmal hier im Chaos Radio das FritzInfo mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Heute Chaosradio zum Thema Filesharing. Was ist das und wie funktioniert das so im Laufe der Zeit mit Erdgeist, Bea und Andreas vom CCC. Und wir haben jetzt schon eine kleine Zeitreise gemacht durch die verschiedenen Arten und Weisen, wie man Dateien austauschen kann, falls ihr das verpasst habt. Wir können es jetzt nicht nochmal zusammenfassen, weil dann wäre die Sendung sofort vorbei. Aber es wird natürlich nach der Sendung einen Podcast geben und den könnt ihr euch gerne noch einmal anhören. Wir sprechen jetzt gleich über BitTorrent, also was das macht und wie es funktioniert. Und vorher haben wir noch einen Anrufer, nämlich den Sven aus Berlin. Der benutzt diesen Usenet-Nachfolger Usenext anscheinend. Und hat dazu eine Frage. Hallo Sven.
Morgen. Meine Frage ist folgende. Wie gesagt, Usenext nutze ich nur, bin auch angemeldet und bezahle auch meinen jährlichen Obolus. Meine Frage ist, wie angreifbar bin ich? Weil es werden ja doch Daten von A nach B in größeren Mengen und das bleibt ja nun nicht ungesehen. Sind das normale Daten, die jetzt aufgreifbar sind?
Was meinst du mit angreifbar? Angreifbar im Sinne von hackbar oder angreifbar im Sinne von was kann ein Rechtsanwalt machen, wenn er deine Daten...
Zurückverfolgbar.
Bei welchem Anbieter bist du?
Direkt?
Usenext. Na, Daten fallen auf jeden Fall beim Bezahlen an. Du hinterlässt natürlich deine Datenspur in die Richtung des Anbieters. Auf der anderen Seite musst du wissen, ob du eine verschlüsselte Verbindung zu diesem Server aufbaust. Sprich, ob irgendjemand reingucken kann oder nicht. Und wenn die Daten verschlüsselt sind, dann ist erst mal nicht davon auszugehen, dass jemand zwischen deinem Anbieter, also Usenxt und dir, da reinschauen kann, was du jetzt im Detail runterlädst. Da musst du jetzt aber natürlich dem Anbieter vertrauen. Meistens sind die Anbieter nicht ohne Grund noch nicht von ihrer Juristiktion des entsprechenden Landes kassiert worden. Das kann mehrere Gründe haben. Einer kann sein, dass die dort mit den Organen schon kooperieren und sich dort Informationen sammeln und die dann irgendwann mal später, wenn es opportun ist, die rausholen. Es ist halt eine komplette Vertrauensfrage bei dem Dienstleister, bei dem du dein Geld lässt, was der dann mit den Daten macht, wenn es ihm an den Kragen geht. Kim Schmitz zum Beispiel. Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn jetzt sämtliche Kunden bei Megaupload in einer großen Tabelle auftauchen und dann irgendwie bei der Urheberrechtsindustrie diese Tabelle dann im Rahmen eines Deals landet und man dann da belangt wird.
Also alles in allem eigentlich eher Finger weg von lassen, wer weiß was draus wird.
Nicht unbedingt. Du hast da auch irgendwelche Vertragsbedingungen. Du kannst auch mal reingucken, ob es da Informationen gibt, wie mit deinen Daten umgegangen wird.
Das ist die eine Seite zu sagen, das ist ja immer die theoretische Seite. Aber die Frage ist natürlich im Endeffekt immer, wie sehr vertraust du deinem Anbieter? Also der hatte ich in solchen Fällen immer in der Hand.
Und jetzt außer über den Anmeldedaten, die ich dahinter lassen habe, beim Anmelden, beim Bezahlen oder auch über die IP, über die Laufe, weil im Moment glücklicherweise läuft der ganz Spaß noch über Nachbarn. Ganz blöd ist er ja auch nicht. Aber jetzt über die IP, mit der ich jetzt arbeite, ist man da denn zurückverfolgbar oder ist es wirklich klein, gedruckt gelesen und hoffen und beten?
Na, die Logs fallen bei dem Anbieter bei Usenext an. Ich sehe gerade, die haben Handelsregister eintragen, die sitzen in München. Nicht in Russland, wie ich gerade dachte. Ja, die Daten liegen da bei denen. Über die IP-Adresse, über den Zahlvorgang bist du natürlich zurückverfolgbar. Ja, Zweifel ist dann, ob mit irgendeiner anderen Ordnung die IP-Adresse einem Namen zugeordnet wird. Hängt dann immer vom Fall ab, für wie verlässlich diese Informationen gehalten werden und mit welchen Werkzeugen die Daten gesammelt wurden. Aber ich habe gehört, dass es eher doch ziemlich lax gerade passiert. Man geht mit einer IP und einer Uhrzeit zu den Betreibern und sagt, wer warntete. Und die rücken das dann auch raus.
Also, es ist schnell, geht zum Datenübertragen, aber ist auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie anonym oder geschützt. Sven, ich muss jetzt leider abbrechen, weil wir noch Anrufer, noch viel zu besprechen, nicht viel Zeit haben.
Die Info, die ich haben wollte, nicht hören wollte, habe ich gekriegt. Sven, wünsche ich noch einen angenehmen Abend.
So, und dann haben wir noch den Martin aus München.
Hallo.
Du bist es aber nicht von News Next.
Nein, nein, bin ich nicht.
Du hast eine Frage, mach es ganz schnell.
Okay, und zwar, wenn man jetzt MP3s zum Beispiel als Datei betrachtet, sind es ja eigentlich nur lange Zahlen. Und jetzt wollte ich wissen, wo praktisch juristisch der Hemming-Abstand zwischen einer legalen und einer illegalen Datei ist. Der Hemming-Abstand ist praktisch der Abstand zwischen zwei Zahlen, also wieviel sie sich unterscheiden. Und jetzt könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, ich habe ein Bild und ich habe eine MP3-Datei. Das Bild ist jetzt legal bei Wikipedia und die MP3-Datei nicht. Da könnte ich ja die miteinander zum Beispiel verschlüsseln. Und wenn ich jetzt oft genug verschlüsselt, dann ist praktisch sehr viel urheberrechtlich Material, also sehr wenig urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material in sehr viel urheberrechtlich freien Material kodiert.
Das kannst du gerne machen, aber wahrscheinlich wird es niemanden mehr interessieren. Also, was willst du mit so einer... Das ist eigentlich ein Remix und du bleibst damit unterm Radar. Also wie oft in dieser ganzen Filesharing-Geschichte ist es, wenn du irgendwas in einer geschlossenen Benutzergruppe in echt kleinem Kreise machst, juckst du die halt nicht. Und erst wenn du zu groß wirst und wenn du ernstzunehmende Schäden verursacht, dann kommst du da aufs Radar und wenn du jetzt da so ein bisschen juristisch spielst und versuchst so eine Datei noch hin und her zu entkoden, dann ist sie für den Großteil der Benutzer da draußen nicht mehr simpel benutzbar und dann sind sie da auch nicht mehr hinter dir her. Und ansonsten ist, wenn du jetzt direkt auf diese lange Zeichenkette da anspielst und meinst, wie muss man sie verändern, dass es dann irgendwie nicht mehr das Original ist, ist einfach der gesunde Menschenverstand. Also wenn du jemanden zwei Musikstücke vorspielst und dann sagst, naja, ist er dasselbe, dann ist es meistens auch dasselbe. Und so den Richter musst du davon überzeugen, dass es jetzt irgendwie aber ein anderes Lied ist, weil da ein paar Bits drin anders sind, dann guckt er dich schief an und dann hast du ihn da nicht überzeugt.
Ja, aber es ist immer interessant für das eine Zahl, urheberrechtlich geschützt, und das andere nicht. Das könnte ja zufällig ein Lied gleich meiner DNA sein oder ähnliches.
Ja, das will aber keiner hören, für mich.
Und noch zum Thema LAN und FDP, schönes Camp war das letztes Jahr.
Martin, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Tschüss. Tschüss. Das ist eine interessante, aber eher theoretische Diskurs, die man in dieser Stelle nicht mehr führen kann. Jetzt haben wir noch eine Viertelstunde, und müssen jetzt BitTorrent und Cherhoster anstarten. Was ich für euch nicht schaffe, deswegen würde ich an dieser Stelle sagen, für BitTorrent verweisen wir auf die Chaosradio Seite. Es gab bestimmt schon mal ein Chaosradio ganz ausführlich, wo das Thema BitTorrent besprochen wurde.
Es gibt auch ein Chaosradio Express, was wir mit dem Tim Brittle abgemacht haben, extra mit den Betreibern vom OpenTracker, von der Instanz, die jetzt auch bei The Pirate Bay lief, und da haben wir das in aller epischer Breite ausgewälzt.
Okay, dann also, wir genügen uns jetzt damit, zu sagen, dass es auch Peer-to-Peer-Datei-Austausch ist.
Aber besser.
Aber besser, und auch mit einem Index, der sozusagen zentral dezentralisiert ist, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Es verdient sich da keiner eine goldene Nase. Also weder The Pirate Bay, noch...
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Damals gab es diese Mailbox mit den Ratios, und dann gab es die von Kim Schmitz, wo er die dicke Kohle eingefahren hat. Und BitTorrent ist irgendwie wie damals mit den Ratios. Jeder lädt etwas ein bisschen hoch, und jeder lädt etwas ein bisschen runter, und dann passt es schon. Und das mit RapidShare und mit Megaupload ist halt eher so, jemand hält die Hand auf und will Geld dafür, dass er das nicht lässt.
Lass uns gleich über die Sharehosters sprechen, ich will nur sagen, man ist schon auch, also Freunde von Freunden sind schon auch so Seiten über den Weg gelaufen, wo diese Torrent-Zuchmaschinen quasi, wo man dann auch irgendwie Kohle zahlen sollte.
Wo der Trog ist, da kommen wir mit den Schweinen.
So sieht es aus.
Aber es funktioniert auch ohne.
Es funktioniert auch ohne. Es wäre mit den Sharehostern ja genauso. Aber da ist es sozusagen verbreitet.
Da musst du ja... Weil die Bandbreite, das ist ja ein ganz entscheidender Unterschied. Bei Peer-to-Peer zahlt jeder seine Anschlussleitung und damit sind die Kosten für die Bandbreite des Hochladens gedeckt. Also jeder hat seine 5 Megabit Upload. Und insgesamt ist es genug, dass er auch alle runterladen kann.
5 Megabit Upload.
Ich habe 10. Ich habe VDSL.
Angeber. Okay, also Sharehostern. Ganz kurz zusammengefasst. Sharehostern funktionieren. Also ganz kurz so, ich lade meine Datei dort hoch bei dem Anbieter. Und jeder, der den Link dorthin kennt, lädt die Datei wieder runter.
Genau, so funktioniert das. Das ist im Prinzip eine Webseite, wo Daten liegen. Und da ist natürlich der Unterschied. Da gibt es den zentralen Server, wo alle runterladen. Das heißt, die Bandbreite fürs Runterladen fällt nicht verteilt über alle Nutzer an, sondern die liegt bei einem, nämlich dem Anbieter. Und der muss das finanzieren. Also braucht man Geschäftsbrüder dafür. Also hält er die Hand auf.
Wie ist das jetzt? Aber die gab es ja relativ lange, diese Sharehostern. Die sind jetzt irgendwie relativ schnell irgendwie am einknicken. Seltsamerweise, obwohl das ja mal alles legal war. Aber wie konnten die sich so lange halten?
Na, die konnten sich deswegen so lange halten, weil die ja ein legitimes Geschäft angeboten haben. Also ich habe eine Seite, da lade ich was hoch. Und wenn dann ein Rechthaber gekommen ist und gesagt hat, da liegt aber was, das gehört mir, haben die gesagt, tut uns leid und haben das gelöscht. Und dass es jetzt Megaupload an den Kragen geht, liegt im Wesentlichen daran, dass da wohl Mails aufgetaucht sind. Also irgendwie sind die Mails des Betreibers von Megaupload der Betreiber in den Händen der Verwertungsindustrie gelandet und deren Rechtsanwälten und die konnten halt anhand dessen nachweisen, dass Megaupload also nicht nur wissentlich in Kauf genommen hat, dass da Sachen hochgeladen werden, wo andere Leute nicht so glücklich damit waren, sondern das sogar gefördert haben. Die haben Leuten Geld dafür bezahlt, dass sie bestimmt Inhalte hochgeladen haben. Und das ist das, weswegen es ihnen gerade an den Kragen geht.
Da hat sich dann ein Gericht in Virginia für zuständig erklärt. Die haben gesagt, also wir haben hier Server, die wurden in unserem Bundesstaat angemietet. Wir haben Leute, die hier aus Virginia dort was runtergeladen haben. Und wir haben hier Leute, die Geld dafür bekommen haben, dass sie was hochgeladen haben. Haben jeweils für diese drei Fälle Personen benennen können. Und hatten dann plötzlich einen Pfeil und haben gesagt, okay, der Schaden ist hier entstanden. Ihr habt ganz eindeutig, auch wenn ihr in Hongkong gemeldet seid, oder die Firma in Hongkong existiert, habt ihr euch an den amerikanischen Markt gewendet. Ihr habt Zahlungen von Amerikanern ganz klar entgegengenommen. Und damit ist es ein Fall hier für unser Gericht. Und wir nehmen die Klage an und haben dann damit um Auslieferung gebeten. Und da Kim Schmitz da in Neuseeland sein Anwesen hatte, respektive noch hat, haben sie sich dann an Neuseeland gewendet und gesagt, hier gegen den liegt bei uns gerade ein Haftbefehl vor. Bringt den mal bitte vorbei. Und in Neuseeland ist das auch strafbar. Und deswegen hat Neuseeland gesagt, machen wir. So ist dann Kim Schmitz dort ins Netz gegangen, hat sich noch in sein Penningroom geflüchtet und wurde dann da rausgeschnitten. Aber jetzt sitzt er da erstmal und wartet dann, also Bailout wird er wahrscheinlich nicht bekommen, und wartet darauf, dass er dann in die Vereinigten Staaten zum Verfahren gebracht wird.
Jetzt ist ja so, normalerweise, wenn so eine Festnahme eines auch irgendwie gearteten Dateiaustauschdienstes stattfindet, ist die Solidarität in der Netzgemeinde relativ groß. Das war ja dieses Mal, lasst es mich diplomatisch von mir, nicht so der Fall.
Na, es ist halt keiner von den Guten. Also er hat halt seit ewig schon durch Freunde verpfeifen, und aus dem, wo man eigentlich versucht, in schöner digitaler Nachbarschaft einfach so datenfreundschaftlich untereinander zu teilen, hat er versucht, seit jeher ohne Rücksichtnahme auf verwandte Geldsäure rauszuschlagen, hat auch ein kleines Ego-Problem, mit dem früher schon bei allen Hackern angeeckt. Und auch der Megauploadservice ist eigentlich nicht im Hacker-Mindset verwurzelt, und deswegen ist es nicht verwunderlich, dass da jetzt ein bisschen Gehässigkeit aus der Hacker-Szene auch entgegenschlägt.
Aber gibt es jetzt sozusagen nur für den Typen, oder auch für diese Art und Weise, wie Dateien ausgetauscht werden, also dieses Share-Hosting, wie es so schön heißt?
Ich denke für beides. Also ich persönlich finde, dass dieses Share-Hosting, wenn jemand daran sich eine goldene Nase verdient, dass das Kids einfach nichts bezahlen wollen, ist für mich Grund falsch. Ich will, dass man teilt, dass man was anbietet, wenn man was bekommt, und das soll nicht Geld sein. Sondern es soll bandbereiter sein und vielleicht eigene coole CC-Musik oder Betriebssysteme, die man da per Bithorn verteilt. Das ist so das Bild, was ich vor Augen habe, wenn ich da an Peer-to-Peer-Technologie hacke.
Generell, gilt es für diese Art von Plattformen? Wie sieht ihr beiden anderen das?
Megaupload ist für mich eindeutig auch die Content-Mafia. So wie die andere Content-Mafia, nur dass der Künstler nicht fast nichts kriegt, sondern gar nichts. Okay, es gibt Ausnahmen. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass es wohl Hip-Hop-Künstler gibt, die auch bei Megaupload Geld verdient haben. Die Sachen hochgeladen haben und dann über den Umsatz, den die Werbung generiert hat beim Download, was verdient haben. Und dies ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schade, die auch daraus für sich als Künstler noch ein Existenzmodell generiert haben. Aber im Großen und Ganzen sehe ich jetzt zwischen einer Time Warner Sony Universal und einem Megaupload keinen strukturellen Unterschied.
Was sagt die Juristin?
Na ja, eine juristische Meinung ist, ich finde, dass das Urheberrecht mittlerweile zu weit geht. Wir sind kulturell darauf angewiesen, dass wir das, was schöpferisch aus einer Gesellschaft herauskommt...
Warte, zum eigentlichen Schlusswort, was ich später komme. Erstmal nur die Share-Hoster, also diese Art und Weise von Dateien austauschen.
Na wenn keine Lizenzen da drauf sind, das ist kein Problem.
Jetzt ist ja so, mit Megaupload relativ viele Share-Hoster, also alle Namen, die ich kenne, außer RapidShare, haben gesagt, wir fahren unsere Dienste mal ein bisschen zurück. Also anscheinend ist denen klar geworden, dass die da nicht ganz viel anders aussehen. RapidShare, wie ist das eigentlich? Stehen die einfach am längsten oder haben die einfach ein Geschäftsmodell, was tatsächlich nicht nur auf diesem Austausch...
Die haben, glaube ich, die beste PR-Agentur. Dass diese Interviews da aufgetaucht sind, das ist so ein Mädel aus der Schweiz, guckt man sich andenkt, irgendwie Klosterinternats-Schülerin. Also so sieht die aus. Also könnte keiner Fliege was zu leide tun, die dann irgendwie darüber redet, dass es doch irgendwie ja bloß um eine Cloud-Dienstleistung geht und irgendwie Cloud-Service sind doch gerade in. Was ja also auch nicht völlig von der Hand zu weisen ist, aber die haben, glaube ich, einfach die beste PR und die besten Anwälte. Nicht so richtig. Also ich meine, natürlich ist das, was Megaupload da getan hat, mit der gezielten Förderung von Leuten, die da interessanten Content hochgeladen haben. Also die haben sozusagen, wenn es irgendwo einen aktuellen Film gab, jemand hat den hochgeladen, haben die Leute Geld dafür bekommen. Und wenn Leute sich den Film runterladen wollten, dann haben die das so eingestellt, dass irgendwie dieser freie Download gerade nicht gereicht hat, um es ruckelfrei zu gucken. Also das war schon sehr darauf optimiert, da aus Content, wo die Verwertungsrechnungen nicht da lagen, Geld zu ziehen, das wussten die auch und das war auch klar. Und natürlich gibt es einen Markt für eine Cloud-Dienstleistung, wo man einfach Dateien hochladen und dann wieder runterladen kann. Das will keiner bestreiten. Und man kann jetzt RapidShare nicht unterstellen, dass die auch so arbeiten. Man müsste eigentlich sagen, dass sie vielleicht nicht so gearbeitet haben. Aber Wissen tut man es nicht. Die wissen wahrscheinlich auch ganz genau, wo ihr Geld herkommt.
Ich glaube, dass es am Ende einfach nur daran lag, dass Kim Schmitz dieses unsägliche Megaupload-Video letztes Jahr gemacht hat. Und irgendwann, du zeigst dir nicht den Stinkefinger, ohne dann...
Dann kam die Geschmackspolizei. Aber wie gesagt, für die unerwünschte Vervielwälterung von Privatkopien sind Cherhos, also scheint es zumindest erstmal weg vom Fenster. Aber anzunehmen, dass damit Filesharing in diesem Raubmordkopie-Sinne aufhört, ist ja wahrscheinlich illusorisch. Was sagt ihr denn, wie wird denn das denn in Zukunft aussehen?
Also P2P hat immer noch eine Chance. Der große Schritt bei BitTorrent ist ja jetzt weg von zentralisierten Trackern hin zu Distributed Hashtables zu gehen.
Das heißt, es gibt...
Ja, naja, ja.
Dieser Magnet-Link, der funktioniert so, dass man...
Halt, ich möchte irgendwie diese zentrale Indizes und sowas... Also pass auf, pass auf. Es muss immer Seiten wie die Pirate Bay geben, wo man sozusagen nachschlägt, was man runterlegt.
Aber inzwischen hatte Pirate Bay auch schon noch dafür Ärger bekommen, dass sie den Tracker und den Index betrieben haben. Und wenn man jetzt Torrents herunterlädt, die so eine ganze Datei beschreiben, dann ist das für die meisten Richter auch schon wieder zu viel.
Und jetzt müssen wir, glaube ich, doch kurz Trecker erklären.
Also es funktioniert so.
20 Leute wollen dieselbe Datei runterladen. Einer hat sie und die anderen laden sich stückweise das runter. Da muss es irgendwo eine zentrale Stelle geben, die weiß, wer gerade die Datei hat und wer daran interessiert ist. So ein sogenannter Trecker. Und das Torrent-Fall, da steht drin, aus was für Stücken so eine Datei besteht. Und das ist natürlich ein zentraler Angriffspunkt, weil der zentrale Vermittler, der sagt, wer mit wem reden muss, um die Dateien zu kriegen, den kann man dann weglagen, beschlagnahmen und so weiter und so fort. Und da gibt es jetzt ein neues technisches Konzept, die Distributed-Test-Table. Da gibt es das nicht mehr, sondern da gibt es nur die große Wolke, wo man dann so eine Frage reinstellt, kennt jemand die Datei? Und dann kommt von irgendwo eine Antwort, ja, ja, ich kenne die Datei, hier sind andere, die die auch haben, weil sie die zentrale Stelle wegfällt, die jemand betreiben muss, die angreifbar ist juristisch. Und das ist sicherlich eine Richtung, in die es noch ein bisschen weitergehen wird, also das vielleicht zusammen mit Anonymisierungsdiensten, wie zum Beispiel Tor, kann man sich also vorstellen, dass das Spiel noch ein bisschen weitergeht, die Dateiaustausch zu erlauben, ohne dass es einen zentralen Angriffspunkt gibt. Und natürlich muss es irgendwo ein zentrales Verzeichnis geben, aber...
Ah nee, das Tolle ist ja, dass so ein Magnet-Link, der passt in Twitter.
Den kannst du in der Twitter-Nachricht tun. Also alles was du wissen musst, ist der Magnet-Link einer Datei. Und das sind halt so 50 Zeichen. Die kannst du im Zweifelsfall auf einen Zettel schreiben. Die kannst du per SMS verschicken. Kannst du einen Twitter-Link tun. Die kannst du im Chat mal eben reinpasten. Und damit fällt der zentrale Punkt weg, wo man das unterdrücken könnte, wo man das blockieren könnte.
Aber das heißt, das heißt, es wird so diese zentralen Suchseiten, wird es auch wahrscheinlich aber trotzdem geben. Werden die dann das nächste Angriffsziel für die Content-Industrie?
Ja, aber da ist irgendwie der... Das ist schon dann schwierig zu konstruieren, wie das angreifbar sein soll. Also wie ist der Magnet-Link noch so? Was ist daran illegal, ist die Frage.
Na, Isohand zum Beispiel hat sich ja in den letzten sechs Jahren ziemlich erfolgreich gegen alle möglichen juristischen Angriffe gewährt, weil sie halt keinen eigenen Tracker betreiben, sondern wirklich nur die Suchseite. Und ist so ein kleines Familienunternehmen, machen da halt nicht viel Geld damit, aber haben einen Auskommen und haben dort schon recht erfolgreich argumentiert, dass sie nicht Dateien zur Verfügung stellen, sondern nur Beschreibung von Dateien. Und damit haben sie sich bisher rauswinden können aus juristischen Gemetzeln. Und das funktioniert da schon noch ganz gut. Also das ist schon noch vor der letzten Verteidigungslinie, weil da kann man noch Torrents runterladen. Und wenn Isohand wirklich irgendwann fallen sollte, dann wird es halt andere Wege geben. Sowas findet man halt auch in Google. Also dann wäre dann Google die Suchmaschine der Wahl, mit der man Magnetlinks findet.
Das heißt aber sozusagen, unter der derzeitigen Rechtsprechung, es gibt aber wahrscheinlich doch schon Versuche, dass man das vielleicht noch verschärfen kann. Habt ihr da noch was? So wie es gerade beschreibt, ist der Krieg zwischen Contentindustrie und Filesharern vorbei?
Ja, er ist natürlich nicht vorbei. Die Contentindustrie fährt ja gerade auf Super, Pippa, Akta und lauter andere vierbuchstabige Abkürzungen. Die schaffen wir, glaube ich, auch in den nächsten fünf Minuten nicht mehr zu erklären.
Nehmen.
Aber es läuft darauf hinaus, dass sie gerne das Recht hätten, irgendwie alles abzuhören und alles abzuschalten, was ihnen in den Kram passt. Also die Bandagen werden härter.
Na, jetzt sind es halt keine kinderpornografischen Bilder mehr, sondern jetzt ist es, in den Vereinigten Staaten war es dann halt, die Urheberrechtsindustrie, die da hergegangen ist, wollte das mit dem SOPA sich da mal ins Gesetz lobinen. Und dann haben sie mal ganz kurz einen Shitstorm aus dem Internet erfahren. Also, du weißt, dass du verloren hast, wenn Google seine Seite wegen dir schwärzt. Und damit war dann erst mal SOPA fürs erste Ad acta gelegt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht ein Schuss in den Fuß gewesen ist, weil jetzt mal sich Leute damit ernsthaft damit auseinandersetzen, um zu gucken, wie groß ist denn diese Industrie eigentlich, die da grad wadenbeißt und lobbied und wie wichtig ist die. Und wenn da Google daher kommt, wenn Wikipedia daher kommt und so einen Terz macht, wie stehen die dazu eigentlich im Vergleich zur Bedeutung für die Gesellschaft? Das hat Obama gestern in seiner, vorgestern an seiner State of the Union, noch mal gesagt, dass er einen besonderen Wert darauf legt, dass auch Urheberrechte im Ausland gerade wahrgenommen werden und sie dort versuchen, alles Mögliche dafür zu tun. Aber ich glaube, dass da schon Sie verstanden haben, dass man das Netz nicht kaputt zensiert, um der Urheberrechtsindustrie das Wort zu reden.
Na, schauen wir mal, ob das klappt. Man kann da ja noch skeptisch sein. Das war auf jeden Fall das Chaosradio 175. Eine kleine Geschichte des Filesharing, das es wahrscheinlich weiterhin geben wird. Keine große Überraschung, aber wir wissen jetzt zumindest, wie es angefangen hat und möglicherweise auch, wie es weitergehen wird. Und da werden Magneten anscheinend eine große Rolle spielen. Erdgeist, Andreas und Bea, vielen Dank fürs hier sein.
Euch einen schönen Abend.
Und wenn man genaueres wissen will über den Chaos Computer Club, kann man jeden Donnerstag bei euch vorbeikommen, richtig?
So ist das.
Die Bea haben wir einfach mitgenommen. Die ist hier vorbeigekommen, jetzt zum zweiten Mal. Schwupps haben wir so eingepackt.
Und Schwupps habe ich eine Menge gelernt.
Einfach verhaftet und dann direkt ins Radio, verrückt. Hier in dem Radio drin gibt es nach dem Chaos Radio Henrik Schröder mit dem Night Flight und Punk-Musik. Dabei wünsche ich viel Spaß. Den Podcast dieser Sendung erscheint in wenigen Stunden schon auf RitzC und später noch auf ChaosRadio.de. Dabei viel Spaß. Mir bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.